kill yourself yeah it's funny games no
gang wars like it's actually like a
romantic game I'm scared of heights
I don't wanna let go oh you did yo are
you fine Oh
grab my hand grab my hand you got you
brush I got you no let go whatever
change now in the Train you got to be
very careful not to step on the tracks
like we do don't look in come on it we
got it okay ma'am we're so dead you know
don't take don't take my odds I'm trying
I'm trying to jab okay you know what I
have to you have to save yourself okay
oh okay
well I lift you up Santa my buddy do it
help me help me please please please
let's go in do it it was a trap not yeah
where did you go let me in hello hello
where did Matt say go you can run bikini
Wow ever except I
I want to go up there I want to go I
want so bad I'm trying yeah party hard
party hard trying to go hand stuck in
the elevator okay there we go
it was also do it do it you can't do
that everyone knows you can't do that do
it do it yes I made it
Pike or what are you doing no don't
ballad I'm a mu do your what huh you
know what a model needs her cone maybe
let me get you all right go do that it's
like you have yet to beat me in a fight
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah see about that do
me bro I'm ready for your broke fighting
me bro oh yeah brother yeah just like
that bro I just love it wow I'm dead I'm
dead what are you doing you have to
finish me I'm trying dude you have to
like grab me and pull me in the yeah you
got me no my mom yes come back come back
come back let me go let me go
we haven't yet if we jump on it it
breaks and we'll go down a little bit
yeah you know how that
what you say English whoa
or does that mean gee like my girlfriend
huh oh oh you gotta save me you gotta
say everything you say please I wanna
make my blood is in your hands you come
on we could have Co had fun you didn't
have fun with me
you know what I want to want and what I
wanna know
thank you what everybody Madhu don't be
mad I want to jump in there okay help
you if you have me my Grammie grab my
head okay grab my head grab it okay you
got me no way no way oh you have to go
in the front you have to go in the front
and then you do like BAM just like that
let go of my neck
thank you probably know what are you
doing my dear now thank you don't care
so you see the blue bar that's how long
you can hold on to can you see me know
if you notice that don't sass me step
sizing me you know every time I make
alright every time you embarrass me God
I do what I have to do yeah your ass is
mine yeah no no you live what this video
doesn't get flagged I don't even know
but it's also a love story it's a love
tender love let go I don't care Oh Molly
yes what are you doing trying to live my
life
oh don't let go Wow okay I'll wait for
you or not yes you can see it alright so
what do you want to jump oh all right
stay there I'll come for you sure
yeah yeah yeah you're not bothered by
the ELCA why do you always do that
why do you always do that thank you she
wasn't so crazy she would still be like
hey I had a hmm Oh a side before
actually I forgot to tell you what do
you mean me too
yeah for the whole media yeah good
forget to tell me it was long ago
outside at the hairdresser oh no I
forgot about it I am sorry I'm a human I
make mistakes you sure thank you me
time to finish it I don't mean to do
this I swear okay okay just that you're
laying down I don't know what to do
seriously God oh no no I'm not gonna
yeah this feels good I think it's hard
to finish your off you know that section
okay now and you can't finish you
somehow don't know come back go
did you wake up here like what is he
doing
yes it's working
yes yes I am the winner actually not
because I'm not a fried potato that's
what I really can't eat it
wait what's that well I want it to be
exciting yes yes okay come here now now
it's pretty exact number so that's this
is my gum do you see the somersault
victory
I win everything you enjoy what I will
see you in the next episode brofist
how's it going brows what what what did
you do forgot messenger right okay let's
play